so there's a very Sinister new character
that now is becoming a prominent player
in right wing media and it is really
reminiscent of Soviet era propaganda not
only in substance but also kind of in
appearance and you'll you'll see what I
mean in a moment some relatively short
period of time ago Donald Trump hired a
new spokeswoman and that spokeswoman is
a woman named Liz Harrington and I'm
going to play a couple of clips of her
from the media from the last couple of
days and it is not only what comes out
of her mouth mouth that is sort of out
and out soviet-style propaganda
even the appearance is weird where like
it's not clear if it's a green screen or
or what's going on but even like her
skin tone and the the production value
is reminiscent of like Cold War era
propaganda and or hostage vid type
videos
um and it's it's all very very crazy so
let's take a look at this first clip
this is from real America's voice the
war room with I guess Steve Bannon I
don't know let's take a look at this and
um you know this could be straight out
of uh of of the Soviet era Russia the
one they can try to raid as many Donald
J Trump supporters as they want we're
just going to keep coming we're going to
keep pressing forward we're going to get
the truth about the election and
everyone will believe it everyone
already knows that this election was
wrong that something was not right it is
15 months since the election she's
talking about 15 months and much like we
we've seen in propaganda movements
elsewhere you know North Korea insists
uh Kim Jong-il really got a hole in one
on every hole the first time he played
golf and controls rainbows and you know
all this different stuff and nobody
believes it but at the same time
everybody sort of pretends to believe it
and they keep repeating it and you have
to go along similar to the things we
hear out of Russia similar to things
we've heard from you know all sorts of
different places and the production
value
uh is like a cross between
Soviet propaganda videos and old 90s
video games I used to play like Duke
Nukem 3D I mean it's all just strange
but 15 months later folks they are
saying the evidence is coming any day
now we're going to get the evidence uh
here's another clip also again I don't
know if it's a poorly lit green screen
or what it is but the appear she looks
like she's being held hostage and here's
a longer propaganda clip
you know Liz I think one of the reasons
a lot of our colleagues in the old media
don't want to talk about it is they know
he is going to be a forced Azure in the
next election I recently saw a little
letter that uh Governor youngin sent the
president thanking for his help in
getting elected in Virginia that's
something that the mainstream media
doesn't want to talk about but tell us
about how Donald Trump is going to play
a role in the 22 2022 election yeah as
Kevin McCarthy and troops tried to take
tell us the house and the Senate
well the power of the endorsement that's
another thing that is ignored by the
fake news but it's not ignored in the
world of politics I can tell you
everyone wants the Trump endorsement
they're always hounding us for that ever
uh important endorsement because they
know it will put them over the finish
line so now it's not really true that
Trump's record is so good I mean in the
2018 midterms to go back to a midterm
Trump endorsed 75 candidates and about
half of them won 55 percent won
it's not that good particularly when you
consider the power of incumbency and a
bias to success when you're endorsing
incumbents during Trump's entire
presidency 2017-2021
ballotpedia attract
305 Trump endorsements and then when he
left office he made another 49
endorsements that's 354 total his record
was 77 percent one and again there's a
major bias to success because he mostly
was endorsing incumbents and incumbents
usually win so his record really isn't
that good but it doesn't matter they
have now gone fully in this you can't
believe what anybody tells you you can't
believe what you see you can't believe
what you hear you can't even believe
what you believe is to be evidence even
that you have to doubt you have to
believe
what Liz Harrington tells you from her
bizarre bizarrely lit extremely weird
screen that that she's coming to you
from uh and this is likely going to
continue and if and until you know
yesterday we talked about the whole
Rogan thing Rogan's saying people aren't
smart if they listen to me for vaccine
advice and much the same way the people
that are watching this stuff are people
who don't have the critical thinking
skills they don't have the media
literacy wherewithal to question the
messages and the things that they are
being told and so in all likelihood
they're going to continue believing it
and the impacts of that are certainly
going to be felt in the midterms hey
this is this is kind of funny
um we are now on Rumble the right wing
Network we
um we they Rumble claims to be the Free
Speech platform everything's allowed
it's all allowed respectfully it's all
everything everything's just all good
so we put some of our content up on
Rumble we have
247 subscribers as of right now we're
just putting our liberal content on
there and we're going to see what
happens we're going to figure out are
they really the Free Speech platform or
do we get ourselves banned do we get
ourselves Shadow banned because remember
all of the claims that the right wrongly
makes about platforms like YouTube
Facebook where the right dominates
Twitter Etc
all the claims that they falsely make we
will now test on Rumble do they
de-prioritize us do they ban us whatever
now maybe they don't I am really
interested to see what happens you can
find our Rumble page at davidpackman.com
Rumble it'll redirect you
um and you know you can subscribe to our
Channel or whatever if you do we had a
really good time during our stream with
this make sure you're leaving comments
about just how great it is that we
finally have liberal content on here and
whatever that being said
uh a lot of people are not thrilled that
we are on Rumble one guy who goes by the
handle American guy almost immediately
when we posted our first clip showed up
and said and here come the Liberals with
their socialist agenda to corrupt this
beautiful website we need to protect
free speech by Banning these satanists
and satanists misspelled as well
um that doesn't sound like the model of
free speech that the platform is founded
on doesn't
um another user said I think this is the
only left-wing channel on Rumble well
Jimmy Dore is on there I thought he was
left wing maybe not
um American guy then tracking us all
over we posted the Marjorie Taylor green
struggling to breathe while talking
about mask video an american guy says
she's struggling to breathe because the
demon rats keep forcing her and her
constituents to wear a mask but she's
there every day at the White House
fighting the good fight actually she
doesn't go to the White House and making
sure laws follow the Constitution
um and then lastly
a user named parancho says you hypocrite
criticize Rumble in Rumble while
profiting from it you must be another
lib Obama fan
so needless to say we are not exactly
being welcomed with open arms on Rumble
but it is a very interesting experiment
and I look forward to seeing what
happens if we get banned I will
absolutely tell you and you can find our
platform there davidpackman.com Rumble
okay I want to make the announcement
where we want this to be a big Community
event so I'm starting to announce it now
we are now three weeks minus three days
I guess that would be like 18 days from
Joe Biden's much anticipated State of
the Union Address now you might remember
last year the Republicans and some on
the right way media were saying Biden
can't even stand for half an hour he's
not even going to be able to put a
coherent sentence together he's going to
be sundowning at night all these if it
was a completely normal uneventful State
of the Union
this year it is particularly anticipated
yes the right Wingers are still doing
the dementia stuff but it's particularly
anticipated because number one Joe
Biden's approval rating at this point in
his presidency is equal to the lowest
we've seen in the polling era and I mean
you go back to LBJ John Kennedy uh Bush
won Bush to ever uh the prior prior to
Biden the lowest approval at this point
in time was Trump and Biden's approval
is down as low as Trump's was so the
real question is is anything going to be
done at the State of the Union to try to
immediately bolster that approval rating
and one of the things that I think is
under consideration this is my
speculation but insiders in DC are
saying there is pressure on this some
kind of renewed mission accomplished on
covet which some people are very much in
favor of and other people are very much
against if it doesn't happen before the
State of the Union I expect that
something will happen there
pushing a return to normality so we will
be live on March 1st starting an hour
before the speech on YouTube twitch and
Facebook I hope you'll join us and in
the meantime let me know on Twitter at
dpacman what you expect to see at the
next State of the Union
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
welcome back to the show the David
packman show is viewer and listener
supported media you can sign up at
joinpakman.com to get instant access to
the Daily bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show you can get the show six
hours before the general public every
day which is just on another level uh
sign up at joinpakman.com coupon code
wow22
saves you a bunch of money let's go to
the phones uh you can talk to me when we
take live calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
slash Discord let's go to oh I don't
know how about uh let's go to Jack from
Indianapolis first today Jack you're on
the air what's on your mind
Jack from Indianapolis please
uh hey David uh so I got a couple of
questions for you
um the first one would be uh have you
done any research at all into
the way in which
um music or art subcultures influence uh
politics
not um not as a general topic I mean
I've read and seen documentaries about
specific musical movements for example
or what have you and it's connection to
politics but not as a general topic
oh okay
um yeah I just find that whole kind of
Realm to be
uh fascinating personally just the way
in which uh different genres have their
own kind of political leanings most of
them are left-wing yes there is the
occasional right-leaning uh scene as
well
country music in the U.S tends to be
more right-wing with exceptions of
course you know the Dixie Chicks would
be an exception and there's others but
country music in the U.S certainly is uh
has more of a right-wing uh bent
um yeah and even in recent years country
music has kind of started leaning more
left
um you know I've heard rumors that more
of uh the country artists in general uh
tend to be more left-leaning than than
people think interesting it's more like
kind of private for them I guess though
yeah I mean it also may be it's private
because it would be bad for their ticket
sales if it was public
yeah exactly
um but also there's I mean there's like
things like black metal and
um
uh you know like death metal uh tend to
have more kind of right laning but like
libertarian ideologies versus like you
know punk rock has always been very hard
left but you know the occasional right
wing uh strand like straight edge
culture sometimes is right wing I don't
know
um anyway I just found that whole thing
kind of interesting
um and I guess the second question would
be
um you know you're a drummer right yes
um where can I listen to some of your uh
playing
oh I don't know that there is any I mean
when when uh at one point I was in a
band called ten fingers not ten but 10
like the Tin Man and there may be videos
floating around of uh some of some of
our shows that's the only thing I can
think of offhand
interesting yeah what was your like
style what do you guys play uh that was
like um alternative basically modern
alternative
oh okay that yeah that's kind of cool
yeah um yeah I'll look into that yeah
ten fingers okay all right very good
thank you so much for the call
appreciate it yeah very uh very powerful
questions there let's go to Marcos from
Florida Marcos from Florida you were
next on today
hey Dave hey um I've been uh I've just
been hearing you about some candidates
uh that could be you know for for
election in 2024 yeah I think they got
to be related to uh the January 6
committee uh because they're gonna pick
a republican that's all crazy support in
January 6 and it will be great if one of
the one of them will be uh a candidate
for uh the Democrats now Jamie Raskin is
my favorite he's got great comebacks and
he's really knowledgeable
uh and uh he's got a bunch of support
from different groups uh and then you
know I'm not sure what religion he's he
is but I think you even have support
from non-religious people well here's
the thing with Raskin Marcos so let let
me mention I think Jamie Raskin is
extremely smart
fantastic public speaker has done an
incredible job with the Trump
impeachment you know years ago and he I
think he's a fascinating guy
um I think that he is going to have an
issue because he is Jewish I think that
there are people who don't want I mean
there's anti-Semitism in the U.S on the
right and on the left and I think Jamie
Raskin among other reasons may have a
little bit of an uphill battle because
he is Jewish but I think he's an
interesting guy I just don't I just
don't see him as even running to be
perfectly honest
yeah I think Jamie is as Jewish for uh
uh race but not necessarily a Jewish
believer well you know you've opened up
a very important question that's a
that's the vast majority of Jews I mean
the Jews in the United States who are of
course ethnically Jewish as you're
pointing out many don't literally
believe the teachings I I am I am one
such person you know I'm not a religious
person at all but I identify with the
Jewish community and ethnicity and
culture yeah no you're you're right the
problem is the anti-semites don't care
about that
right right and then the other questions
real quick is about Florida it's a bunch
of stuff going on in Florida yeah with
the uh they're banning books from the
schools yes uh they're uh now they
they've got Nazis all over the place and
the Republican party is not not saying
anything about it basically I'm worried
about we already have uh Christian
nationalists in the military yes uh you
know if Michael Flynn was it's just one
of them and uh it's queuing on as well
and now we got Nazi so uh maybe they're
in the military and it could be pretty
bad uh yeah you know the Banning of
books is similar to what happened in
Germany when they burn books because
they were on German and now they're
doing books because uh they're not white
or they're not religious uh the school
board said something last week about in
my area about saying well if you can't
read uh you know a book in in church you
shouldn't have it in your library you
know that's pretty bad that is pretty
bad it's it's horrible what's going on
in Florida the other thing you didn't
mention which we talked about earlier
this week on the bonus show is that
they're moving this don't say gay Bill
through the uh Senate where teachers in
primary school won't be allowed to even
talk at all about sexual orientation or
gender identity and we we of course
understand the homophobic and
transphobic nature of that it's wacky
what's going on in Florida I'm actually
I have a couple of invitations for shows
that film in Florida and I'm thinking
now that coveted cases are down so low I
may do it soon so I may be down there
doing a little investigating of my own
before you know it
but let me know when you come by maybe
we'll meet all right yeah we'll grab an
espresso okay
thank you all right very good there's
Marcos from Florida yeah I mean it's uh
it's a covet hellscape but the weather
is nice okay let's go next to um
where are we gonna go next let's go to
where are we going let's go to Chris
from Massachusetts who I believe is
already unmuted because they're a
moderator Chris from Massachusetts
you're on the air
hey David hello
Hey so uh um I posted this just kind of
um puts it in the pack fails Channel I
was hoping to get some
get your thoughts on this what do you
think about
the Democratic party uh it really
started to embrace well I'm not saying
that they're doing this but I think it
would be a good strategy of embracing
the politics and the policies of people
like Katie Porter rather than the squad
there seems to be
a
cultural difference uh but I always say
there's a difference in how
Katie Porter and members of the squad
approach some of these cultural issues
that are important yes
um but they also Katie Porter does a
really good job of you know holding
uh people accountable especially in
these interviews that we've seen go
viral uh on 100 listen I think that
there's two different things going on
here you've correctly identified that
culturally Katie Porter has a different
a tone and approach to issues than the
squad and for me as it as an individual
uh I tend to like Katie Porter's
approach
a lot I didn't like it a lot but I think
there's a more important piece it has to
be said Katie Porter's much more
knowledgeable on a lot of these issues
than the squad types and I I'm not
saying it pejoratively I'm just saying
Katie Porter has more experience
particularly in the space of finance and
economics and she's more knowledgeable
and so what I like the most about the
Katie Porter approach it's less cultural
for me it's more about she's just so
knowledgeable that you get the sense
that she's not only crafted a series of
questions that will look a certain way
she understands the issues in detail
that are underlying all of those
questions and and I love the Katie
Porter approach I think your idea is
great
yeah and if you look I mean she you know
was one of the few
um freshman uh Congress people to flip
or a historically red District yes and
that seems like you know when you look
at the fact that the younger people that
tend to support you know the squad types
the most they don't show up and vote so
the Democrats are kind of stuck with
trying to
try to influence as much of the
independence to come out and vote for
them as they possibly can yeah and I
think and these cultural issues turn off
those independent types but Katie Porter
especially with their background in
education she has like this really I
mean she's so skilled at pointing out
exactly how people's pockets are getting
picked yep by you know Banks you know uh
a lot of these you know property issues
she was gonna I mean she was going to be
uh I think like a housing advisor for
Elizabeth Warren
um and like you said she's so
knowledgeable on these issues and she is
just able to really communicate to the
people like this is how you are getting
worked over by the people in power
that really kind of uh resonates with
with across the Spectrum and how she was
able to flip a district so I I think
that you know
really the energy should AOC is
extremely popular ilhan Omar also
popular you know and they have their
their place but I think like I think you
know
if we're gonna put
as the res we're going to put our
resources into the place where it's
going to have the most impact it's
getting behind people like Katie Porter
I agree I think in the context of the
conversation about 2024 nominees I don't
know that Katie Porter is is an
appealing nominee to a lot of people but
that's a different question and I think
everything you've pointed out is
absolutely true
all right thanks David all right thank
you so much for the call uh very very uh
very good point let's go next to John
from California John you're on the air
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
fine it sounds like it sounds like
there's birds Where You Are
uh yes I'm actually outside on the front
porch is it like a tit mouse or some
kind of parrot what is that
uh no I did it's in the distance I'm not
really sure yeah no problem what's going
on we're going to Nature
so I had a
oh and we just lost you it sounded like
you were about to say you have a and
then I'm guessing the word was question
but then we just we lost you completely
are you still there
or
um so I was wondering um so even if it
can even if there is a divide
um wouldn't even wouldn't the
Republicans still end up voting for
whoever the Republican primary is anyway
like because yeah I know you said it
still benefits Democrats in a way but I
think when eventually they would
eventually just go Republican because
they want to vote Republicans okay so
John we we lost the first half of the
question but I believe I know what it is
which is even if there is a republican
Civil War for now aren't Republican
voters eventually just going to vote for
whoever is the nominee is that was that
roughly your question
yep that's correct okay I think they
generally will so like for example right
now you've got anti-trump Republicans
formerly Trump Republicans and Trump
Republicans all battling they're
battling over was it an Insurrection on
January 6. they're battling over should
we censure people like Liz Chaney and
Kinser okay fine
eventually aren't they all going to vote
for the nominee the answer is they
mostly will but
when the left isn't really bringing
anything super inspirational to the
table
what we have to hope is that some of
those Republicans will just be disgusted
that their wing lost and they'll stay
home I don't think it's likely many of
these Republicans would vote for a
democrat in 2024 but if the Republican
Party continues the infighting hopefully
some of the Republican voters will just
get sick of the whole thing and opt to
stay home
okay that makes a lot of sense okay
because yeah okay that makes a lot of
sense thank you David and I just have
just two quick questions I know that's
just a quick answer that you'll have
please both of them
um one the second one or the first one
is do you think there is I know you're
not a virologist but do you think
there's a possible another variant
that's out right now that we don't know
of because I know you said it takes time
to to for us to figure out one yeah so
this is not my opinion I mean it's what
what virologists say is there absolutely
are variants out right now that we don't
yet know about that's just the way it
works the question is do any of them
become concerning and we just don't have
an answer to that yet
okay thank you and the second one is
quickly have you ever thought about
contacting Discord about notification
and disruption during calls because it's
I know it's annoying I know it's
annoying for you
I I think Discord would say we have we
have features to turn that off and just
explain to people how to do it you know
I don't know that discord's going to do
anything special for me but okay yeah
that makes sense all right thanks a lot
all right thanks John I appreciate the
call John from California dropping some
serious knowledge on us uh okay we're
gonna take a very quick break but we're
not ending calls okay so if you would
like to speak to me just hang on because
I'm going right back to the phones in a
moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from a few more people in the audience
we are taking calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord I hope I
pronounce this name correctly is it
Zephaniah from Kansas Zephaniah is that
correct
yes it is how are you
I'm pretty good I just want to say I'm a
big fan of your show and I have a
question about Joe Rogan and his podcast
please so a lot of a lot of his episodes
were taken down because of his use of
the n-word so you know spot you they
don't have people don't have freedom of
speech on Spotify they're put they're a
private company they can do what they
want but would you support Spotify
removing content from anyone
um who uses that type of language
because I think it's kind of
hypocritical for him to to be
his content to be removed when he's
using the word and whatever regard and
then you have you know rap artists
talking about killing people and
destroying their communities using the
n-word all the time so would do you
think that would be fair to just remove
anyone who used that language okay so
here's the thing what I what I want to
see is Spotify explain the policy and
apply it fairly now
the policy could be okay and I'm gonna
this this is where it gets complicated
if if Spotify wanted they could say
listen our policy is
unspoken word podcasts we don't allow
the use of the n-word except in what are
clearly
academic
some kind of academic use where you have
some kind of Sociology Professor who's
explained I don't even know but like
let's just say the policy could just be
unspoken word podcasts we don't allow
the word that being said we allow it in
uh music or something like that now
would that make sense I don't know I'm
not sure I don't know if that would make
sense but what I what I think has to be
done is what whatever the policy is
it has to be applied to everybody it
can't just be to Joe Rogan that's that's
my priority the the next part of it is
there are tiny podcasts
uh and and musicians with oh that almost
nobody knows about that are certainly
using the word and so then it becomes
does Spotify even have the wherewithal
to police every minute of audio that's
on their platform I don't know I don't
know but what I am absolutely certain
about is whatever the policy is can't
only be applied to Joe Rogan that's for
sure
okay thank you very much all right my
pleasure there's Zephaniah from Kansas
uh let's go next why don't we go to
let's go to Boris from Denver Boris uh
what's going on in Denver these days
hey David it's just really cold oh okay
there's some stuff here and there but
not too much I wanted to ask you been
doing some reading for black history
month and I was curious I I have an
answer to this that I think you would
agree with but I was thinking these days
if Martin Luther King was around would
the right try to smear him as being too
woke
oh my god of course oh this wow yeah
absolutely you know now you see many
Republicans Now sort of slickly try to
appropriate themselves of Martin Luther
King and say you know we we love the
ideals of they'll list a few people
they'll be like Lincoln and Reagan and
Martin Luther King or whatever they they
would be smearing Martin Luther King as
a wokster socialist and I mean yeah
without a doubt without a doubt
yeah and the thing that really drives me
crazy is a lot of them like I've even
seen the new governor of Virginia they
try to quote him when they pass a lot of
these anti-critical race theories yes as
if he as if to suggest that Martin
Luther King was opposed to critical race
Theory and he was just like uh you know
in American loving person who just
thought oh America's is just a little
flawed but it's a fundamentally great
country and all that but they'd ignore
what he said like America is racist and
all that and one other thing I wanted to
ask about this do you think that
could you see a future I seriously can't
see one where they will try to smear him
anyways when like his files get released
in 2027 and the FBI Files show that you
know he maybe was involved with you know
their allegations that he uh that he
didn't uh stand up to a friend that was
like raping a woman or something like
that he was like casually
um uh he was like in the room as some
woman was getting raped and he didn't do
anything about it or something like that
listen I've never heard that before so I
want to be I don't know anything about
that I couldn't possibly make any
predictions about that I want to be I
just I've just not heard that I couldn't
comment on that
okay well I've I've seen there was like
a report that came out not too long
probably a few years ago yeah I saw
Gavin McGinnis did on his show and even
Tucker Carlson tried to cover and I
think they were just trying to like I I
just felt like it was the start of what
I had seen 10 years from now the right
is going to completely portray Martin
Luther King as this uh bad person yep I
think I mean they'll do both things they
they will attack Martin Luther King when
it's convenient and they will take
credit for Martin Luther King when it's
convenient and they're already kind of
doing it
yeah okay last thing before I get off uh
do you have any plans or would you if
you post to going on back on Joe Rogan's
podcast I I have no I've not been
invited I would go back on anytime
okay cool I'd love to see you uh back on
there hopefully you can help of course
correct thank you I would love love to
do it all right thank you so much for
the call very much appreciate it let's
go next to Dave from is it heldsburg I
can't quite see
it's Healdsburg sir thank you so much
I'm honored to speak to a freaking
Predator heal yes thank you heal hold on
I have that drop that is a freaking
Predator where is Healdsburg
Hillsborough is in Sonoma County just
North of San Francisco 75 miles
beautiful area
yeah I'm currently standing in a
Vineyard it's uh It's a Wonderful Life I
gotta get back up I've been to a bunch
of The Vineyards there and it is just
great there's this I believe in uh we're
I believe in downtown Napa there's like
a high-end food court called the uh oh
man I don't even remember it's just it's
just a great area
I very much uh enjoyed myself this year
my whole life so well what's on your
mind
I just want to talk about Joe Rogan as
well okay everybody
um little context I started with Joe
Rogan at episode 36 in June of 2010. I
never missed an episode until October
2020 when I couldn't take it anymore the
covidia Sea and the things that he was
saying about politics in General vashing
on Biden uh see me ignoring all the
problems with Trump uh I more or less
gave it up but I've gone back to
listening when the pandemic uh is out
and I think people are are missing some
significant things here the audience of
Joe Rogan
they don't care about fact checkers
they don't care what the mainstream
media says and the more they attack him
the more they're going to run to him yes
if there's any chance that course
correction somebody needs to go on the
Rogan podcast and talk him out of the
bad ideas that he has
clung on to
um and I don't know who that person is I
wonder if you have any ideas no I don't
I mean I don't know that there's any one
person who can talk him out of
everything I think it's you know with
Rogan it's a lot of
he'll he'll listen to anybody he has on
the the challenge is getting the right
people on and I'd be glad to be on any
time with him I'm not an expert in a lot
of the areas in which he's allowed
incorrect information to Fester I'm
aware of the fact that the information
is wrong but I'm not an expert in that
but I I don't think there is any one
person I think it would take sort of
like a concerted effort of bringing on
different types of guests for an
extended period of time quite frankly
yeah I mean I think what you could do is
point out to him that he's far too
inclined to accept a person's supposed
qualifications I mean even as his
apologies
when he came on the first time
um video he immediately threw out the
qualifications of Nicola and Malone as
well that alone makes anything that they
say true yes which is just absolutely
wrong and then of course
um when it came to the the apology for
the the inward video a previous caller
just got it wrong I I don't think
Spotify took those down I think Rogan
took them down I think uh he got tired
of having those out there
um out of thousands of episodes what's
it matter if there's 110 it only
benefited him as well because now people
think he's under attack and people are
taking his his episodes now yeah I mean
the thing the statement was that Spotify
has taken them down what you're
suggesting is that what's been reported
isn't true which is possible but I think
it's meant it we should be clear that
this is just your opinion
yeah and that's based on what he said in
his uh in his apology video for that
um I just I think it's uh it's far more
likely that he didn't want it out there
anymore because he saw himself in the
video and and like you said it made him
sick to to his stomach just to see
himself saying those things so no harm
in taking him down when there's
thousands of episodes It's not like
anybody was gonna go listen to him I
mean that's the thing with McCullough
and Malone's episodes too put fact
checks on him take him down censor them
it doesn't matter if that information is
already out there at this point
the Rogan Mantra of uh the only thing to
do with bad speech is to combat it with
good speech is the only strategy that
can work going forward I agree that you
have to go on and talk in those ideas
David I'm a huge fan uh have been for a
long time member and uh this has been an
absolute pleasure thank you all right
thanks Dave appreciate uh appreciate
your your support and as a member Dave
gets access to the much derided bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad all
right let's go next and talk to
let's go to Chuck from Pittsburgh Chuck
you're on the air
hey David can you hear me yes I can
uh so I don't really have any questions
but I just kind of had some thoughts to
put out there
um one is like we have like all these
people on the right that talk about like
their pro-life and stuff yeah and I've
never heard any like I wonder what their
views would be because I feel like a lot
of these people are also like racist
like what's their what's their views on
like like racist pro-life because I feel
like a lot of these people like don't
like black people or Jews and you know
like what would their what do you what
do you think their views on that would
be what what I don't even know what what
are the reviews on racist pro-life what
does that mean well so like a lot of uh
I feel like a lot of racists are also on
the right and a lot of like pro-life
people are on the right yeah
um like that that aren't for abortion so
like what would their thoughts be on
like uh a black person have an abortion
like do they even care or you know what
I mean well they claim to and then this
is actually something that the pro-life
right will use they'll say abortion is
incredibly racist because look at the
use of abortion by black pregnant women
and it's it's it's particular so they
whether they're racist or not they
pretend or claim to be concerned about
aborted black babies as part of their
anti-abortion stance now you know
whether they're genuine in that concern
or not is a totally different question
to basically just playing along to act
like they care about their their views
well I don't I don't want I can't say
act they claim to care I think is the
point and whether they do or don't I
don't know
yeah and then uh just another thing too
like I'm from Pittsburgh to that bridge
that bridge collapse yeah I saw on uh
on Facebook a lot of people were like
commenting on the thing and a lot of
people are just complaining about like
you know we pay taxes and why wasn't
this taken care of and it's like
I I feel like a lot of these people also
don't realize that like like I
understand the bridge was in poor
condition but like also like you could
just have like a a bridge that was in
great condition and accidents can happen
like
yes statistically speaking I mean we
have sort of a normal distribution where
like for the most part if the bridges
are fine they're not going to collapse
every once in a while you get bridges in
terrible shape that don't collapse and
every once in a while you get a bridge
that's okay as far as Engineers are
concerned and it does collapse but
correct me if I'm wrong the bridge that
collapsed did not have a good uh
structural rating did it did it not
correct correct yeah it was in poor
condition yeah um I was just saying
though like I saw all these people
commenting about like you know I can't
believe they would let this happen and
stuff and it's like well yeah it was in
poor condition but like I mean accidents
can happen it could have been in great
condition and happened too yeah it could
and also there's dozens of I mean there
was a report there's like dozens or even
hundreds of bridges in New Jersey with
the exact same condition and they'll
mostly be fine but this could happen
again at any time
yeah exactly but yeah I mean I like I
said I didn't really have any questions
uh been watching since probably about
the beginning of the pandemic when
everybody kind of hyper
focused on uh politics yeah because of
all that so but yeah I'm a member like
the show and just keep up the good work
all right thanks Chuck very much
appreciate it that's gonna do it for
calls today we will take a quick break
and be back with much more and if you
didn't get on today there will be more
opportunities
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get to the mailbag
people loving the mailbag emails pouring
in about the mailbag info
davidpackman.com is the place to write
to abuse it and lose it
120 viewers now Auto filtered into the
trash because they are sending too many
emails okay let's get right into it one
of the best parts of when we stream
large Live Events like a trump Rally or
a debate
or whatever
is lots of people looking for coverage
of that event who have never heard of
our show stumble across the stream and
this generally is a great thing it's one
of the fastest ways that we grow our new
audience the downside maybe it's sort of
like a funny you know it's a mixed bag
is people who are right-wing nuts Who
stumble across our coverage and then get
really mad when they realize that they
are
um watching a left-wing stream and I got
a bunch of those I got a bunch of those
thanks to the Trump rally AR wrote in I
can you're an absolute [ __ ]
I continued listening to Trump's speech
but I'm sickened by your idiotic
commentary learn a bit of History you
[ __ ] you're more interested in
giving a commentary on the audience than
anything of importance in the speech
that's absolutely untrue and I take
issue with it can't wait to see you give
Applause during Joe's Next Guard garbled
unintelligible lie ridden diatribe to
six people
um I can't think of any time I've
applauded during a Joe Biden speech
finishing with your with y o u r y o u r
it's almost legally required in hate
mail that the wrong your versus your is
used you're a total c word
sent from my iPhone
um okay so this this is one of the
greatest Parts about covering Trump
rallies people just looking for the
rally stumble across and are highly
triggered triggered triggled uh
triggered and people just looking for
the rally are stumble across us and go
hey I like this guy I'm going to
subscribe to the channel
um similarly Mitchell wrote in in all
capital letters about our coverage of
the Trump rally
who said Mr Pacman misspelled of course
as a conservative American I love my
country
I love our Constitution and people like
you are a pathetic libtards
the way they love the Constitution is
weird because much of what Trump said
during the rally was completely uh
indicative of not caring at all about
the Constitution
excuse me do Society a favor I'm choking
over the words do Society a favor and
commit succide I think they meant
suicide get the F out of my country what
a country we live in folks what a
country
uh don't know that there's much more
commentary to make about Mitchell's
email
and then lastly
as many of you know Alex Jones recently
went after us Infowars conspiracy
theorist going after me for looking like
a predator and uh not taking Live phone
calls which of course we do he attacked
the bonus show as well oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad yeah uh and here's our message
from Bobby who was really pleased with
the the infowar segment watch Infowars
today hahaha it was very sweet watching
you get completely busted on Infowars
you are a total loser suck it a-hole BS
artist what I love love love about that
particular message
is that Alex Jones is so diminished in
his audience because he's been kicked
off every real platform he's off YouTube
he's off Facebook
I can't even I think he's off Spotify I
don't know
um he is he he has almost no platform
left so at the end I only got two emails
and one voicemail from people who saw
the Alex Jones segment and agreed with
him it's it's really something how his
platform has just evaporated almost
completely all right next is Kate Kate
has a good let's get now to the
substance Kate Rhoden why do far-right
Republicans keep burning things hey
David as a frequent listener you peaked
my curiosity when you mentioned
Carhartt's vaccine mandate for employees
and how that caused right-wing customers
to burn their own clothing I couldn't
help but see a parallel
between this and the Nike items being
burned and destroyed after Colin
Kaepernick protested police brutality
and racial inequality in 2016. well also
remember when they threw their Keurigs
out the window why do far-right
Republicans keep burning things what
does this accomplish what's next books
the plan well but yes books the planet
they're already doing that I truly don't
understand this might be worth inviting
a guest on your show with a background
in Psychology or something of the like
to discuss and investigate further thank
you for being such an honest engaging
source of Truth yeah if anybody
I don't know exactly who would have
expertise in this but it would be very
interesting to speak to someone
uh who can explain
psychologically this phenomenon of
burning stuff and the flame retardant
Carhartt Clothes impervious to burn
attempts from their very people it's I
mean you you really can't write this
stuff but uh a very uh if anybody can
suggest such a guest as Kate is
mentioning we would be glad to reach out
to them
Kristoff writes in about couldn't care
less David sir I watched your segment
today about the poorly capitalized
Tucker Carlson Today Show and his
misogynistic propensity for a
patriarchal society there was audible
cheering in my house when Carlson's
guest said I could care less about what
people call him and you stopped the clip
to correct the statement absolutely
using that phrase incorrectly drives me
insane because it makes zero sense to
the point of the individual supposedly
not caring it is very common to hear it
phrased incorrectly even by Highly
Educated people thank you for correcting
it why do you think it's so difficult
for people to use couldn't instead of
could for the phrase I don't know I mean
guys listen it's think about it
logically
if you could care less you're saying you
care
right imagine the phrase
I could care less but I actually care
more
so the correct phrase is I couldn't care
less I care so little I couldn't
possibly care any less because I already
care zero
please guys please go out there into
your communities and do what you can to
make sure that the phrase is used
correctly I appreciate Christoph
noticing
my commitment
to that phrase and quite frankly I could
care less about how the phrase is used
and by that I mean I care I hope that
that's clear to everybody Stephen wrote
in with an existential question
and wrote Our traditional peanut butter
cookies actually candy
traditional peanut butter cookie recipes
consist of peanut butter sugars eggs and
sometimes vanilla is it candy
um so I think the answer is no and I'm
going to give you two reasons why first
of all many peanut butter cookies as
their primary ingredients have peanut
butter and or flour
now I know that there are peanut butter
cookie recipes that contain no flour and
so you've got peanut butter and then
often it's a very high amount of sugar I
still think that they're not candy I
think we could consider them junk food
but candy typically has as the primary
ingredient sugar
or chocolate like chocolate-based
candies would have chocolate and then
sugar so I don't think and this is a
question of Paramount importance I don't
believe that peanut butter cookies can
be qualified as candy but I am open to
having my mind changed on that
all right here's a really important
email I got last week during the Tucker
Carlson patriarchy Jason Whitlock
segment I said
that I don't have any problem exploring
questions about men and women
that
they're you know preemptively shutting
down areas and saying we can't talk
about that I have a problem with but we
need to understand what it is we're
looking to do with that information and
whether we actually already have the
information and claiming that we're just
asking questions is a way to troll
because we already know the answers I
got an email that from a female fan
who said David flirting with misogyny
David listen I just watched your video
called Tucker guests as patriarchy is
good and I was a little put off by the
way you spoke about it sure you
acknowledged that the idea of a natural
patriarchy is wrong but then you said
you're open to investigating potential
biological differences like math
aptitude my goodness imagine you said
you're down to investigate whether
Asians are biologically better at math
than whites it's been investigated
they're not
or whatever come on now I get that most
of your audience are likely dudes but I
think they can handle it no need to
coddle their egos in this way this is a
really sad email it is now 2022 and it
blows my mind even educated humans like
yourself are still saying s like this
just sounds ignorant sir I'd even say
you're flirting with misogyny I'm a
fanboy I'm a fan but boy that was
disappointing to hear I could not
disagree with this more strongly I am
against saying
here's a list of questions you can't
explore at all
you you just can't explore it I mean
listen guys if it turned out women were
way better at cardiothoracic surgery for
some reason that didn't relate to
economics or geography or whatever right
like if women were just we imagine we
researched it and we determined there is
something inherent women are better at
cardiothoracic surgery
I would want to go to a woman for
cardiothoracic surgery now it might turn
out that because of historical
oppression against men in that field
this is a this we're making this up that
there's really no that there's a there's
an observable difference which we can
explain to discrimination I would also
want to know that why would we say that
can't be looked at
so I think it's very dangerous when
folks take this approach that you can't
even ask these questions the issue I
have is that these questions have been
asked for a long time and we have
answers to just about all of them and as
I pointed out there's no evidence that
uh women are less capable for jobs other
than circumstances in which there may be
a physical limitation okay listen you
got to lift 200 pounds and many men and
most women can't lift 200 pounds so
you're restricted to mostly men and a
small percentage of women who can lift
200 pounds okay we've got an explanation
uh but I I am very concerned about these
things where these things cannot even be
explored part two by the way is if you
explore things like this in a fair way
the imperative is what are you gonna do
with the information is the information
going to be used to discriminate is the
information going to be used to insult
or or even worse that's also a factor so
I am not one of these just asking
questions people and every question I
ask is being asked specifically and in
bad faith to justify discrimination the
more of these questions that get asked
the more we learn that discrimination is
inappropriate and it's wrong and it's
unproductive okay but the email saying
you you can't even ask that
that that's not the left I recognize
that's not the left I recognize at all
uh okay last email here from William
offering pardons to the writers isn't
Trump also signaling to Future rioters
that he will pardon them thus setting
the stage for election related riots in
the future yes to some degree
so at the Conroe Texas rally when Trump
said
um first of all not only did he say we
may pardon some of the writers he also
said we're going to have some of the
biggest protests ever sort of again
alluding to more violent protests
because that's what a lot of his
followers want to do
um he absolutely is starting to plant a
seed about future potential repeats in
different contexts of what happened on
January 6th and uh his devout followers
know it they recognize it and it's very
very dangerous what we have to do is
prevent Trump from being in a position
to be able to convince people to do that
send your emails to info
davidpackman.com uh we have a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com and you will get instant
access to today's bonus trip
foreign